here are five easy ways to tell if he's  physically attracted to you number one  when you get close to him you notice his  nostrils flare this isn't a coincidence  it's actually because he's sniffing you  for something called pheromones  pheromones are the chemical that  determine compatibility like if you guys  would make healthy babies together so if  you notice simpler as nostrils he's just  subconsciously sniffing you second sign  he's super physically attracted to is  that when you look at his eyes his  pupils dilate this is because as humans  we tend to fixate and hone in on the  things that we like and the things that  we're after what have I told you about  body language science okay that's a  that's a sign it's a fake science you  put it in the same realm as like  astrology no you cannot read every  little movement that a person makes and  then draw these wild conclusions